[Musique]
louise
qu'est-ce qui se passe j'étais pas prêt
à laisser partir pour toujours tu me
fais peur témoin ce que tu as fait tu
avais marre tout il fallait que je la
fasse revenir dans un endroit que je
suis très loin dans la forêt plus loin
que cimetière pour animaux
je connais mes inter revient est
contente de me voir manu
en bastide à bastille
il faut qu'il se repose assumer au lit
elle veut pas de moi non on en a besoin
de temps c'est tout c'est rien fait pas
d'elle de toute façon cimetière au
cinéma le 10 avril en se promenant dans
la forêt il y est tombé par hasard sur
un endroit tout à fait charmant un
cimetière pour animaux
c'est un endroit où on enterre son
animal pour pas l'oublier ça peut faire
peur mais y'a pas de raison c'est
complètement naturels comme la mort est
naturelle donc la ville utilise cet
endroit depuis des générations
les gens en ont fait une sorte de rituel
c'est pas des histoires j'ai vu ce
symbole sur les arbres c'est un
avertissement
les indiens qui vivaient là les sons
graves et avant de fuir
vous avez peur de cet endroit quelque
chose habitent cette forêt quelque chose
qui remonte à très loin
quelque chose à qui ses terres par
tiennent quelque chose le ça était mort
fait revenir à la vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je sais ce que vous voulez faire mais
quand ils reviennent ils ne sont plus
les mêmes
ah ah oui ce qu'est ce qui se passait en
baisse d'affilée j'aurais jamais dû vous
montrez sept mois c'est pas seulement
votre enfant qui va revenir
la barrière est brisé
on a une seconde chance parfois liés à
pire que la mort